the eight people killed in the attack
have now been identified they include
two Americans 32 year-old Darren Drake
and 23 year-old Nicholas Cleaves a 31
year old mother of two young children
from Belgium also died the other five
victims came from Argentina DeMarco
Morgan is in lower Manhattan at the
corner where the suspect began driving
down that bike path DeMarco good morning
good morning to you guys you can see
just how busy this intersection is and
how easy it is for these going to turn
in and make its way down this bike path
here at least eight people are in the
hospital with injuries ranging from
amputations to neck and back engines but
perhaps the words pain as for those who
learn their loved ones will not be
coming home Jimmy Drake is coping with
the loss of his son
32 year old Darin Drake who lived with
his parents in New Jersey together they
tried to reach him after hearing about
Tuesday's attack we should water the
aunts Darin being out in a 30 second
period of time that the guy came driving
by but then as the day went on
Jimmy and his wife identified Darrin's
body Wednesday I think I'd rather have
every tooth pulled out without any kind
of novocaine 23 year old Nicholas
Cleaves was the youngest victim a New
Yorker the software engineer lived just
blocks away from where the rampage
started a mother of two from Belgium and
lured dekat also died her husband toda
belgian newspaper the 31 year old was
the most beautiful mom and lor was with
family on the bike path when the suspect
allegedly ran her over from behind
cell phone video taken just minutes
before the attack shows this group have
been from Argentina who were celebrating
more than 30 years of friendship five of
the men were killed their friend from
Massachusetts 48 year-old Martin Merrill
survived but has neck injuries Tom
mountain is marrows friend not only did
he survive but he's out of danger he's
out of critical care and he's got to
make it President Trump said he spoke
with the President of Argentina last
night to offer his condolences meanwhile
the bike path is back open as you can
see people are running they're walking
and riding their bikes here along with
flowers along this route that's serving
as a reminder of what happened charlie
thank to Marco